good morning believe nation today's
message is maintain a sense of humor
over to you Stephen Hawking although I'm
71 now I still go to work every day and
Cambridge University keeping an active
mind has been vital to my survival s has
been maintaining a sense of humor you
clearly have a very good sense of humor
many will remember your appearance in
the Simpsons the world's smartest man
for my appearances on The Simpsons the
Big Bang Theory and I am for my
scientific discoveries I've made a cameo
appearance on Star Trek my favorite
designs I hope you love laughing again
Albert
I find humor and a few jokes are a great
help in a lecture on the mysteries of
the universe I love this message because
when things are going well when things
are happening for you when you're
hitting your goals and you're growing
and you know everything is a success
around you then it's easy to be happy
and it's easy to have fun it's easy to
maintain your sense of humor the hard
part is when things aren't going well
and as entrepreneurs
you should things are not always gonna
go well so one of the most important
things you can do is maintain your sense
of humor because it's not always going
to be this bad the lows are not going to
always do that low the highs are not
always gonna be that high and the thing
that will help you get through that will
save you from depression that will save
you from wanting to quit and go off and
do something else is making sure that
you are having fun and you're happy and
you're maintain your sense of humor
throughout one of the things that I
found challenging when I first started
my youtube channel was dealing with the
haters and luckily I don't get that many
haters on the channel thank you guys
please don't start hating but it's still
hard when you get those first people who
are really critical of what you're doing
and pointing out all the things that
need to be improved without giving any
kind of positive encouragement and I
think as entrepreneurs we all have these
haters in our life who don't help us
they just try to poke holes in our plans
and one of the things that really helped
me was advice that I got from a friend
who told me imagine the haters are
babies and at the time I had Hayden who
was a baby and it just made things a lot
more fun when somebody left a hateful
comment on my channel I would just think
I would just think about them being a
one-year-old Hayden who was crying and
upset I just wanted attention and it
just made me smile and doing that little
exercise each time kept my sense of
humor even though people were spewing
negative things at me so my question of
the day today for you guys is when
things get tough how do you maintain a
sense of humor
leave it in the comments below I'm
really curious to find out thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of an espresso